نحن الان امام ظواهر جيولوجيه لافته جدا
من من من من بركان سيميرو هنا نحن نقف عند
سفوحه الى بركان كرنتي وغيرها وهناك زلزال
ايضا وقع في منطقه تقع جنوب شرق هذه
المنطقه فيها هذه القريه هي قريه كاجر وهي
ابرز القرى المتضرره من الثوران البركاني
الذي وقع فجر الاحد نلاحظ هنا هذا التراب
الاسود هو الرمادي البركاني الذي زحف نحو
هذه المنطقه من سفوح الجبل طبعا جبل همم
سميره يقع في الجهه في تلك الجهه الى
الشمال الغربي ورؤيته الان محجوبه بسبب
الغيوم والضباب هذه المراه يتحدث تتحدث
فرقه الانقاذ على انها نجحت وتحمد الله
على انها نجحت بابعاد السكان عن اي قتل او
سقوط قتل قتل بسبب الانذار المبكر الذي
وقع مساء يوم السبت قبل ان يحصل الثوران
الاكبر فجر الاحد هذه المنطقه الملاحظه ان
الدمار واضح هذا الطريق كان هذا الطريق
كان يوصل بين محاضرتين اليوم فقط صباحا
جاءت معدات ثقيله
وازالت كميات كبيره جدا من الرمادي
البركاني وصار من الممكن للمواطنين العوده
عبر هذا الطريق واخر امتعتهم المنطقه شبه
خاليه من المواطنين هناك عدد قليل من فرق
الانقاذ
المسؤولين والمتطوعين من الهيئه الوطنيه
للتعاون مع اثار الكوارث وهي تحاول ان
تبعد المواطنين وتعطيهم وتعيدهم بعطائهم
منازل بديله عن منازلهم في هذه القريه وقد
منح بعض المواطنين فعلا منازل بديله عن
هذه المنطقه